Here's a different city map. And in this city, the naming starts here. We have
1st Street, 2nd street, and then it continues. The avenues are the same, but the
avenues run north south. 1st Avenue, 2nd Avenue, and so on. Maybe this is the
intersection of the 0th Street, and 0th Avenue. Now, 0th Street and 0th Avenue
are pretty silly names for streets, but that's okay. And maybe this intersection
is important. It's where the first building may have been built, so residents
called it the origin. I'll just label it 0. Now, I want to think about this
intersection at 5th Street and 3rd Avenue in relationship to the origin. How
would you complete the following statement? How many blocks is this intersection
to the right of the origin? And above the origin. Fill in the numbers here.